I am your host soggy ah thank you so
much for coming out
global leaders with humanity's most
thought-provoking questions onto the
same stage we hope to inspire people to
build the future providing trance which
I coined a long time ago now is
basically the psychological state in
which one defends the concept of aging
for a completely irrational reason
because even if we have a small chance
of actually no it's succeeding with what
we know today in hastening the defeat of
our biggest problem the thing that
causes the most suffering in the world
we damn well ought to be going to that
chance about whether to happen to be
progressively taken away from me by my
declining health with the funny part but
the funny part paradox has plenty of
answers that don't involve us being in
simulation like the Fermi filters well
right so actually they that means that
there's space there's potential filters
that cause a civilization from being
able to evolve to a point where they
could simulate as in something like
mutually assured destruction nuking
everyone or potentially disease I'm
spreading right so by far my favorite of
the various traditional answers to the
Fermi paradox is the cloaking one that
essentially sure okay so plenty of
civilizations may get to the point where
they [ __ ] themselves laughing but the
fact is also there are various
civilizations that get to the point of
figuring out how not to blow themselves
up but they also recognize that some
other civilizations may be not very
peaceful and maybe willing to go and
mess people up right and colonize the
force for example yeah that's right and
the best way not to be colonized with
force is not to be noticed now of course
the day we're aware that we are pumping
our you know radio waves stuff that is
this rather rather indicative of our
intelligence rather fast into it's not
about having radio transmission yeah you
know at the moment but it's not obvious
that we would necessarily need to be
doing that we could quite possibly get
to a situation where we could do
everything we wanted to do down here and
the radio waves we're not getting out if
that were true we might feel that we
were safer from other civilizations
so one perfectly good explanation for
the Fermi paradox is that there are
better civilizations civilizations out
there that have survived perfectly well
for a nice long time but they don't want
anyone to know that they exist so we use
the power of rather than seeing little
tiny ants they're humans they see be
real and remember that's not quite how
it's done right I'm not talking about
cloaking the I'm not looking about
cloaking at the visual spectrum I'm
talking about cloaking at the level of
the radiation that the plant emits into
space that goes arbitrarily far out
right so you could imagine you can
imagine that you know some advanced
civilization if it got close enough
could have a look and you know that's
right but they'd have to take the
trouble to fly by right right and the
question is which of the which of them
which is the very large number of
planets that exist might they bother to
fly by and the answer is the ones that
are emitting radio waves yeah that would
be easiest yeah it's easiest to discover
other species
more than you can put your telescopes on
I mean the the extension of what I'm
saying that you put forward is perfectly
reasonable when I end up cloaking a bit
more you know and and the kind of thing
you say you know there's nothing
particularly difficult about that the
community understood very well that
aging is caused by the progressive
accumulation of damage in the body
molecular cellular changes that
accumulate and progress through our time
and eventually that they get to a point
where the body is not set up to tolerate
them and the overall physical and mental
function that we have declines and
eventually increases but also it's
really really hard to clean up our
metabolism and slow down the rate at
which it creates damage because I
metabolism is such a mess and instead
you can go in and periodically repair
the damage preventatively in other words
before there's so much damage that it
has already caused pathology and if
you're repairing it reasonably well then
you can keep its overall level down
below the threshold that's bad for you
even without having any doing anything
about the rate at which the damage is
being being created in the first but if
you can do reasonably comprehensive
damage repair so that you can keep
people healthy for maybe 20 or 30 years
longer than they normally would be
then you've bought yourself all that
time you can apply those therapies to
someone it already let's say 60 in other
words they're not very far away from
getting the pathologies of old age as a
result of having too much damage you can
take them back in in biological aging
other words in the amount of damage that
they're carrying so they won't have that
same amount of damage again until
they're let's say chronologically 90
well we've got these seven different
major categories of damage that I always
talk about these are very big categories
they sound a little bit like so big that
they wouldn't be useful but they are
useful so one is loss of cells cells
dying and not being automatically
replaced by the division of other cells
so you know that happens in a lot of
different ways a lot of different places
in the body during aging and it causes
problems of course but you might think
well so it's such a broad category why
is it even useful to define it the
answer is because the answer the repair
strategy for all such cases
broadening the same it's stem-cell
therapy that's what you do you know you
but you brief rogue on yourselves in the
lab so that when you inject them into
the body they know what to do they know
how to divide and transform themselves
into replacements for the cells that the
body is not replacing on its own and of
course different stem cell therapies for
different tissues are different but
they're only different in their details
they have a huge amount in common so
once you've got stem cell therapy
working really well for one condition in
one tissue the amount of work that's
involved to get its work to work for the
second one the third one far less that's
why it's useful to have this
classification this taxonomy from that
purely economic point of view aging is
ridiculously expensive
I mean 90% of our medical care goes on
aging and that's of course just a direct
cost that's not even counting the you
know the lost productivity of the kids
of the elderly looking after the parents
or the fact that the elderly are no
longer contributing wealth to society
because they're not well enough to do so
you know all that kind of stuff right so
if we fix all that then the country is
just going to be vastly more prosperous
well that but fundamentally can be
stayed as is these therapies will pay
for themselves at the national level
ridiculously many times over
ridiculously rapidly a population is not
a function of how many people we have on
the planet it's a function of the
difference between how many people we
have on the planet and how many people
we can have on the planet with an
acceptable level of environmental impact
measure whatever way you like climate
change whatever right and forget that
second number is another constant it's
not like it's not like like you know the
speed of light it's not something that's
a universal physical like immutable it
changes as a result of other
technologies hello we're the girls and
leave these technologies that are being
developed in this town you know solar
energy you know artificial means you
know dissemination these are the things
that are going to increase the carrying
capacity of the planet and if you even
think about it it's completely [ __ ]
obvious that these things are going to
increase the
capacity is by far faster than the
population of the planet could possibly
increase even if we completely lamay it
all death from all causes now and
furthermore purposes which are going to
be with high probability available to
everybody you know the so-called ethical
questions that might surround such
applications of secular technology just
disappear because really to my mind the
only way that any new technology can be
a bad idea to develop is if it fulfills
three criteria the technology has to be
something that can be used by a small
number of people to do a large amount of
damage in a very small amount of time if
if any one of those three things is not
the case then you basically don't have a
problem you know sure I mean don't get
me wrong I think there's plenty of
danger from the the the the the advances
of artificial intelligence technology in
general whether you call it a GI or not
I'll give it that unpleasant place I
mean honestly you know you know I'm all
for that I'm not the kind of existential
risk type who says that you know it's
absolutely pivotal that we should
maintain the species at all cost in one
way or another
IIIi can tend to be the kind of person
who thinks that almost everybody dying
is almost as bad as ever
but nevertheless I'm all for not
everybody dying and so absolutely it
would be nice to have off planet
civilization but I wouldn't try Mars I
would build a much more controlling but
yeah yeah that kind of thing yeah that
further away than millions in order to
preserve the species you only need a
fear right and so oh so you'd want to
throw up a hundred thousand in there and
then just in case people have [ __ ] up
enough to want to live in space right
listen if we actually crack this if we
bring aging under proper control it's
not just that we're going to not have
people with Alzheimer's disease I mean
that's awfully wonderful but the fact is
it's also going to help us to see that
we have as a populace of species the
ability to address and to really succeed
in addressing extremely hard problems
[Applause]